und jetzt drehen sie von menschen die
arbeiten was nimmer denn bei einer alten
dame die 850 euro rente bekommt und ein
bundestagsabgeordneter also sie
inklusive ist dass ich verstand hat hat
einen rentenanspruch von 250 euro für
jedes jahr das heißt sie sind da viel
drin ob sie wieder gewinnen und nicht
aber kommen 1000 euro wie erkläre ich
dass den alten menschen die nicht mehr
leben wollen die nicht mal 1000 euro
haben ihr leben lang geschuftet haben
für dieses land aufgebaut ab indem sie
ich unsere füße bewegen wenn ihr
vorbilder sein wollt dann habt ihr bei
euch anzufangen bei euch ja wir helfen
überall aber ihr habt einen eid
geschworen ich sie die anderen sie da
gemacht haben wir haben ein einzel schon
auf dieses land wird auf diese bürger
und diesen iphone
millionenfach unterstützt ein für die
bürger hier
[Musik]